In general, it's like,...
...you find something awesome and the first thing you wanna do is talk about it with someone.
Like, I don't think anyone necessarily shares things because they think someone else will love it.
And, the friends you have are kind of the ones that allow you...
...to like geek out about the things that you are absolutely passionate about.
And that's the reason you stay friends with them,...
...is not because you're talking about things with them,...
...to talk about things that interest them.
It's because it interests you and you're absolutely passionate about it,...
...and they have enough of a commonality to let you explore it.
And that's where having a friend comes in. That's what fun about it,...
...is kind of like, nerding-out and exploring a subject together.